Combien de personne
peuvent faire ça,
en France, ici,
pour un travail
dans le froid.
Quand c’est le livreur
qui monte 5 étages,
6 étages.
Sans nous,
ils ne sont rien.
Donc,
qu’ils nous respectent,
qu’ils reconnaissent
nos droits.
Salut, c'est Juliette !
Dans cette vidéo,
je voulais vous parler
du quotidien
des livreurs de repas.
J'ai passé 48 heures
avec Thomas.
Il a 30 ans,
il vit avec sa femme
et son nouveau-né
et ça fait deux ans
qu'il est livreur.
Tous les jours,
Thomas livre des repas
de 11h à 23h
pour gagner
en moyenne 60 €.
Pour 12 heures de travail,
c'est vraiment
pas beaucoup.
Bonsoir !
Comment tu vas ?
- Ouais, ça va, tranquillement.
- J’ai Antoine et Thomas,
s’il vous plaît.
C’est validé !
Allez, à tout à l’heure !
Allez, c’est parti !
C’est au 20... Combien ?
Au 28 !
28, c’est derrière.
Bonsoir, chef !
- Bonsoir !
- Désolé, hein !
- Ouais, t’inquiète.
- Je suis vraiment désolé.
Je vous remercie, monsieur.
Bon appétit,
passez une agréable soirée.
C’est validé.
Allez, c’est parti.
Ça va, patron ?
Ça se passe ?
Uber ou Deliveroo ?
- Deliveroo.
- Deliveroo ?
Moi, c’est Uber.
Bon courage !
On va faire
un grand détour.
Les routes sont barrées.
Oh là là...
Ah, c’est bon ! Heureusement.
Je croyais qu’il avait pris toute la route.
C’est tacos, non ?
Voilà, je vous
remercie énormément.
Bon appétit,
passez
une agréable soirée.
Allô, bonsoir monsieur.
Oui, c’est le livreur.
Je suis là dans 10 secondes,
même pas, 5 secondes.
Bonsoir, monsieur.
- Merci.
- Bon appétit.
Bon, on va à la place
de Clichy maintenant.
- On va à la place
de Clichy maintenant ?
- Ouais.
Je l'ai rencontré
un soir à Paris,
sur une place où lui
et ses collègues
se rassemblent
en attendant
leur prochaine course.
Quelle que soit la météo, ils sortent.
J’ai une course,
je dois livrer,
j’ai pas le choix.
Si j’annule
les deux commandes,
Uber risque
de me déconnecter.
Avant, les plateformes payaient mieux
ces livreurs,
qui étaient souvent
des étudiants,
mais avec la baisse
du prix de la course,
de plus en plus
de personnes sans papiers
ont repris
ce boulot difficile.
Vous savez
qu’il y a des gens
qui volent des commandes ici ?
- Ah, ils volent
vos commandes ?
- Oui, ils se font passer pour des livreurs.
Ils viennent, ils prennent des sacs et ils s’en vont.
Commande 812.
- J’ai Karine.
- Karine ?
- Deux sacs.
- Ouais, y a deux sacs.
- Pas de boissons ?
- Euh... Si !
Trois boissons.
- À l’intérieur ?
- À l’intérieur, oui.
- Voilà, merci beaucoup.
- Au revoir, bon courage.
- Merci.
Je vais mettre les boissons en bas.
Je vous mets un pouce.
C’est validé.
- Ça marche,
bonne soirée.
- Merci, à vous aussi.
Allez, on s’en va.
On n’a pas le choix.
C’est pour ça
qu’on fait de la livraison.
Non seulement
c’est fatigant,
mais c’est mal payé.
Parce que rester toute une journée sur un scooter,
ça fait mal au dos,
vous voyez.
- Non, on n’est pas
à la bonne adresse.
Oui, oui, souvent
ça arrive.
On te dit "c’est ici",
mais c’est de l’autre côté.
Oh...
Vous voyez, ça aussi...
La boisson
s'est mal fermée.
On n’a pas trop fait
de pavés.
Normalement, la boisson
ne devrait pas
être renversée.
Mais souvent,
quand on met le pouce comme ça,
nous, on encaisse.
C’est pas le restaurateur.
Vraiment, je suis désolé.
- Je vous remercie, monsieur.
Merci, bonne soirée
à vous.
Au moins, lui, il est sympa.
Sinon, il y a des clients
qui disent :
“Non, je prends pas.
Je prends pas.”
Quand je vais mettre
“commande endommagée”,
lui, il va me mettre
un pouce comme ça,
et ce sont mes points
qui diminuent.
Qui m’appelle ?
Allô ?
Oui, oui,
j’arrive, madame !
Je viens de livrer
la première commande, là.
Je viens vous livrer tout à l’heure.
Excusez-moi, madame,
je suis désolé.
Désolé, madame. Désolé.
J’arrive tout de suite.
Quand nous, on va livrer,
on a l’impression que nous,
en fait, on n’a rien
à dire, quoi.
Nous, on est là,
on fait le travail,
comme ça, et puis voilà.
Ceux qui sont pas contents,
ils nous jettent la pierre.
Et puis nous, on est là,
on assume.
Y a des restaurants
qui sont sympas,
qui acceptent
quand nous rentrons
dans le restaurant
pour se réchauffer.
Y a des restaurants
qui sont pas sympas,
qui ont dit
“les livreurs, c’est dehors”,
voilà, alors que
nous représentons
les clients,
donc nous aussi,
nous avons le droit
de rentrer dans le restaurant,
aller aussi récupérer
notre commande.
Je reviens !
Vous voyez,
le problème, c’est que...
les adresses ne sont
pas précises, en fait.
Vous voyez ?
- Oui, oui.
Dans l’autre...
Ah ! Vous voyez ?
Alors que moi,
ils m’ont mis là.
- Je vous remercie,
monsieur.
- Vraiment, rares sont
les clients qui font ça.
Bon appétit.
C’est pas facile !
Tu manges quand
tu travailles
ou tu attends toute
la soirée et tu manges
que quand tu rentres
vers minuit ?
- Oui, oui, j’attends quand je rentre vers minuit.
Ça c’est le portefeuille :
hier et aujourd’hui,
je suis à 51 €,
même pas 100 € !
Là, je fais
ma dernière commande
et puis je rentre.
Avec mes miettes
que je gagne,
j’arrive à me...
à me défendre avec...
avec ma petite famille.
Je peux laisser, peut-être,
30 € à madame.
Elle va s’arranger,
peut-être, pour faire
une sauce avec du riz,
le soir,
pour qu’on puisse manger.
Quand je commence
à bailler comme ça,
ça veut dire que, voilà,
je commence
à être fatigué, là.
C’est la 1DCD.
Louis.
Chef, si c’est prêt,
tu peux envoyer, s’il te plaît ?
Je vois un sac
qui est prêt, là.
Les commandes sont là-bas.
Tant qu’ils n’ont pas encore
fini de tout faire,
ils vont pas ramener,
alors que
nous sommes pressés.
Nous, on travaille
avec le temps.
Tu veux livrer
pour aller te coucher,
mais ta commande est là,
on te la donne pas.
Vous voyez ?
Quand c’est comme ça,
moi, ça commence
à m’énerver.
Je dis
“envoyez la commande”,
il dit
“non, attends, attends”,
alors que la commande est déjà prête.
Ça, c’est la réalité.
On est arrivés à la base.
Le chasseur !
Récemment, beaucoup
des collègues de Thomas
ont vu
leur compte désactivé
du jour au lendemain,
sans être prévenus
ni indemnisés.
Les plateformes disent
que c'est parce
qu'ils travaillaient
sous une fausse identité.
Pourtant,
du côté des livreurs,
on m'a expliqué
qu'il n'y avait pas
que les sans-papiers
qui avaient vu
leur compte désactivé.
Et même,
ceux sans papiers
disent ne pas comprendre
pourquoi on les a laissés
travailler si longtemps
si leurs documents n'étaient pas valides.
Ils se lèvent, comme ça,
un matin,
sans motif,
sans justificatif,
ils se lèvent et ils coupent
le compte de quelqu’un.
Y a des gens qui sont
père de famille.
Ils ont coupé leur compte,
comment ils vont faire
pour nourrir leur famille ?
Qui vit avec ça, qui nourrit leur famille comme ça.
Ils ont coupé
ton compte ?
Lui, il nous fait trop rire !
Vous vous demandez
du coup, peut-être,
comment vous pouvez
aider ces livreurs.
Déjà, vous pouvez faire deux choses :
vous pouvez descendre vous-même les escaliers,
quand vous pouvez,
pour leur faire gagner
du temps,
et aussi, pensez à leur laisser un petit pourboire.
Thomas, en tout cas,
il ne pense pas que c’est
en boycottant ces plateformes
qu’on trouvera la solution.
Chacun a sa façon
de voir les choses.
Si on boycotte Uber,
nous, on sait que
ce sont des gens
qu’on met au chômage.
Nous nous montrons humain, quoi.
On ne veut pas
les boycotter.
Tout ce qu’on a à leur dire :
il faut qu’ils essaient
de remédier à la situation,
en tout cas d’arranger beaucoup les choses.
La régularisation de ceux qui n’ont pas de papiers,
la rémunération
des courses
et puis le respect et la considération aussi.
Merci d’avoir regardé cette vidéo,
j’espère qu’elle
vous a intéressé.
Si jamais vous voulez voir
d’autres vidéos
comme celle-ci,
vous pouvez les retrouver sur notre page YouTube.
N’hésitez pas à m’envoyer un message sur Instagram
si jamais vous avez
des idées d’autres sujets
que vous voudrez
que je traite.
À la prochaine !
Vraiment, c’est moi
qui vous remercie.
Parce qu’à travers vous,
aussi, on peut...
Voilà.
Vous contribuez
à ce qu’on puisse
entendre nos voix, aussi,
et voir la réalité
que nous vivons.